I'm going to start with a nurse's strike
the Royal College of Nursing say that
they want to meet the health secretary
to stop the strike they say they've
offered to negotiate five times but the
health secretary has turned them down
this is what Pat Cullen there general
secretary said he said negotiate she
said sorry negotiate with the nurses and
avoid this strike five times my offer to
negotiate has been turned down I will
press pause on it when the health
secretary says he will negotiate
seriously on our dispute this year that
means each of us giving some ground
what members of the public think it's
extraordinary the health secretary
doesn't appear willing to sit down with
the nurses well the health secretary has
said that he is of course happy to meet
he said his door is open he said that in
the article that he wrote today I think
people need to understand though that
the negotiation on pay is done by an
independent pay review body and so often
we see people saying we need to take the
politics out of this these things need
to be done by independent professionals
so he put in place an independent pay
review body we've accepted and
implemented their findings in full of
course the health secretary wants to
talk to the profession about how we can
make the about make the job better how
we can improve the NHS performance for
everybody but ultimately pay is decided
by an independent people independent pay
bodies in a moment but but the fact of
the matter is you know if they're
willing to sit down and talk to the
health secretary and they've said that
they are five times isn't he hiding
behind this independent pay review body
you know he should meet them shouldn't
he well he said he's willing to meet
them but again we're saying you're
willing to meet them and they're not
meeting them no but but the point is
somebody meet them but the point is
um uh meetings are different from pre
negotiations and through most of my time
when I've been involved in politics
people have said they want they they
keep saying they want to take the
politics out of this we massively value
massively value the work that health
professionals do my mother was a midwife
like many many people in the country
I've got uh good friends uh who are who
are members who are members who are
members who are who are uh health
professionals and we value them
enormously But ultimately independent
bodies are there for a reason is to take
the politics out of this kind of stuff
and and and we respect the Judgment they
made we're implementing it but there is
politics in this isn't there and in the
end it's the government that controls
the person's strings and you talk about
these independent pay review bodies but
when they made these pay recommendations
this was before inflation had gone up to
the level as it is their figures are
some would say really woefully out of
date and these are bodies that are
appointed by the government often
staffed by people who've got a
background within the NHS themselves and
management so some would say you know
question really whether they are that
independent but fundamentally doesn't
the government need to talk to the
people that they're negotiating with
before they even get to the point of
talking numbers they need to physically
sit down and negotiate with the nurses
well so I I think it's uh I I don't
think it's right at all to question the
independence of these bodies as you say
they are they're often people from the
sectors in which they are making
decisions and and of course we recognize
the uh the the value of the work that's
done by the medical professions but
these independent they are independent
pay review bodies are there for a reason
that's what people have been calling for
as I say for most of the time that I've
been involved in politics that there's
real Independence in these
and it's really important to recognize
that the the 19.2 percent uh uh request
would would cost something uh something
in the region of 10 billion pounds to
match just that uh pay award which is
which is which is a larger sum of money
than the 8 billion pounds we're putting
in over the next two years for Health
and Social care to address the backlog
and that's and that's of course the
challenge that we've got to recognize we
are very focused on making sure the NHS
is delivering for the British people we
hugely respect professionals within it
but we have to be sensible it's not
respectful if you're not willing to talk
with them now the RCN have said today
that they are very well that's not the
the health sector has said today that he
is of course willing to talk to them but
the pay negotiations are done through
the internet okay so so will he sit down
with the Royal College of Nursing in the
next day or so and avert the strikes
that we're expecting later this week
well in the op-ed he said his door is
open but we've also made it clear that
the pay negotiations are done through
the independent pay review body so he
won't negotiate pay with the nurses he
will simply say go back to the
independent pay review body well so the
question I ask is is is do do do we
respect those independent people
the fact of the matter is if if the
independent pay review body is saying
one thing and the nurses are saying
another
we've got the health secretary doesn't
appear to be talking to the nurses
directly he's the only one who can solve
it he's the only one who can sit in the
middle and say right this is what they
say this is what you want let's try and
reach a compromise but that is the role
sorry I mean that is the role of the
independent pay review body it's the the
clues in the name it's independent and
it reviews pay Awards who control the
purse strings they're not the ones who
make the decision it's it's a
recommendation they make it's up to the
government it is a recommendation it's a
recommendation and a recommendation it's
a recommendation and a recommendation
that we have agreed to implement but it
just doesn't seem that there's any way
to resolve this then if the government
is saying we are simply not going to
move from what the independent pay
review body says we are not willing to
negotiate at all with the nurses about
about what they believe sorry this
question is going around in circles but
the point is getting a straight answer
sorry you're not getting an answer you
like no but that's different I'm giving
you a Straight Talk
the independent people
dependent pay review bodies were created
to resolve differences between the uh
the the bodies that seeking uh pay
whether they be in the health profession
teaching profession other professions
and the government that hold the purse
strings they are the adjudicator they
were created they are independent of
government they are staffed by experts
that is why they exist they make
recommendations and in this instance the
government has accepted the
recommendation fully but the nurses
don't accept it and it seems therefore
that there is no way to move forward
from this but as I said the the health
secretary has set his door is open uh he
wants to talk to the health
professionals about how we how we drive
performance of the NHS how we make sure
that it's a job that uh that they want
to uh that they want to do that all all
these things but
as I say the independent pay review
bodies do what we ask them to do which
is to review pay independent the
government we accept their
recommendations and ambulance staff are
out on strike this week do you think
people will die because of it well we we
want to make sure that uh people are
safe we very much regret the fact that
um the ambulance service and another key
public services are are going on strike
we recognize there is a huge amount of
pressure on on everybody everybody
because of covid because of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and the inflationary
price pressures that put on household
prices we we do recognize that but the
role of the ambulance service is
important we are looking at contingency
planning to make sure that we can keep
people safe and people should rely on
the NHS they should call 999 if there's
a problem and will work to make sure
that they can be moved from where they
are to where they need to be treated if
people die because they can't get
ambulances who do you think well I'm not
gonna I'm not I'm not speculate on that
we are putting contingency plans in
place we will be working to make sure
that people are able to rely on
Emergency Services
let's turn to foreign policy uh
obviously you're making a big major
policy speech as foreign secretary
setting out a doctrine of new
Partnerships fast-going countries
including Asia Africa Latin America
they're not traditional trading partners
of the UK why didn't we trade with them
in the past well it's not just about
trading relationships this is one of the
points I'm going to make in the uh in
the speech trade is an important part of
a bilateral relationship but a good
diplomatic relations in a number of
these countries where we have a
development Partnerships helping them
develop their economies the the point
I'm making is that if you project
forward over the next 15 25 30 years
there are a number of countries
fast-growing countries who are going to
be increasingly wealthy and therefore
important trade Partners but they are
going to be increasingly influential on
the world stage and I want to make sure
that the the values the principles that
the UK feel strongly about are ones that
we're discussing with these increasingly
uh wealthy yes but influential countries
over the next few decades you talk about
values and principles and let's talk
about Iran it's just carried out its
first execution of a protester for
taking part in dissent against the
regime this is machine shikari he was
charged with holding up traffic
assaulting a guard he's dead
you have talked very tough on on Iran
you've said on Friday you said you want
to hold the country to account you're
imposing sanctions on a small number of
people
but the government's own figures showed
that trade with Iran went up 113 over
the last year how do you square that as
foreign secretary you know one hand
you're saying this is Despicable what is
happening here but we're very happy to
trade with the country in fact we're
happy to do more trade with the country
so I think you'll find that that is uh
an increase on a very very very small
figure and obviously where there are uh
when figures are quite
287 million pounds that we trade with
Iran which which if you look at the
trade figures almost any other countries
is is almost negligible
um the point is that the uh the response
of the regime to uh protesters
internally is completely unacceptable we
called in the Iranian Ambassador uh last
week we summoned the Iranian of
Ambassador last week to uh to hold him
accountable for what's happened we are
sanctioning people who are involved in
human rights abuses as well as the
broader sanctions that are in place uh
as part of our effort to prevent Iran
from acquiring a nuclear weapon um Iran
knows that we feel very very strongly
about this and they should understand
that these are Grassroots protests from
their own people who are criticizing the
Iranian regime for the oppression of the
Iranian people
okay well let's move on to a country
which you do spend even more money with
and that's Saudi Arabia trade with Saudi
Arabia is worth 13.7 billion I noticed
that in this article that you wrote on
Friday you didn't mention Saudi Arabia
81 men were executed there last year and
at the time the foreign office Minister
Alan Duncan said there's a deep
murkiness here that we do not like but
it obviously doesn't stop us dealing
with them
um
up 26 last year the trade with Saudi
Arabia are you proud of being foreign
Secretary of a country that trades with
a country that actually crucifies people
in public well
um I have spoken with the Saudis about
our long-standing principled position uh
on the death penalty as I do with pretty
much all countries around the world that
maintain the death penalty they know
it's a long-standing uh principled
opposition to us Saudi of course uh is
not just economically but but culturally
religiously and Incredibly important
influential country in the Middle East
uh and further it's incredibly important
that we maintain an ongoing bilateral
relationship with uh with Saudi some of
that includes trade but also in terms of
security
counter-terrorism work and when we have
a relationship with the country of
course we highlight where there are
differences and on this issue we have
very very deep differences but we also
seek to find the areas where we can
exert influence and we have I have in
fact been supportive of the reform
program that saudi's putting forward and
we have seen real changes over the last
decade I want to see those changes go
further and faster I believe that many
people in the uh in the Saudi government
would like to do so also but you see the
concern that is it appears that the
British government will deal with
countries that do have objectionable
human rights records if it's if it's
worth it for us and you you're talking
about this new policy that you're going
to embrace lots of other countries a lot
of people will look at that and say hang
on is the is the British government now
the kind of government that will deal
with these states and just hold their
nose if we think that it's good for
trade well look you keep referring to
trade trade is not the only element in
fact in with many of these countries
it's not the most significant element at
all but the point I'm making the point
I'll make in the in the speech is that
we are in a competitive global
environment a number of these countries
that are developing fast are becoming as
I say increasingly influential on the
world stage not just economically but
but uh you know politically
um
what's the word I'm looking for um
diplomatically
are being wooed
they are being they have choices and
either we find a way of encouraging
those countries to move in the direction
that we think is the right direction uh
increase openness
increase you know reform within
themselves as we are doing with Saudi
Arabia and others or we can choose to
detach but those countries will still be
influential those countries will still
be important but those countries will
increasingly increasingly be detached
from us I don't think that's in their
interest I certainly don't think it's in
the UK's National interest so we work
with we work with countries and when we
have disagreements we highlight those
disagreements where we have
opportunities to exert influence we seek
to reserve influence as well what about
Egypt a few weeks ago the uh sister of
Allah Abdel fatah the British Egyptian
political prisoner who's held there made
an appeal to the British prime minister
on this program uh to try and get her
brother's release what progress have you
made well the Prime Minister uh spoke
with President CeCe on this issue I've
spoken with the Egyptian foreign
minister on this I know our officials
speak with Egyptian officials on this
regularly as well so we are working we
continue to work on these Consular cases
both in Egypt and and elsewhere we we we
want to make sure that we
um have access to this person who is a
dual Egyptian British national will keep
working
um and sometimes these conversations
done publicly often they are done
privately but I can assure you in the
viewers that we continue working on this
there haven't been any specific
diplomatic consequences have there well
as I say we we do continue to um
to the Egyptians about this I know we're
not alone in doing that okay let
situation in Ukraine early this week
Vladimir Putin said Russia could reach
agreements about Ukraine in the future
and reading the runes do you think there
is any possibility that it could
potentially be peace talks on the
horizon well ultimately of course we do
want to see peace in Ukraine we see the
brutalization of the Ukrainian people we
see the impact that that war is having
on on on grain prices and grain of
availability around the world I've just
come back from Ethiopia where
um the the impact of the war in Ukraine
is is being felt with regard to food
insecurity so of course we want to see
this resolved but we have always made
the case I have always made the case
that any negotiations need to be real
they need to be meaningful they can't
just be a fig leaf for Russian
re-armament and further recruitment of
of soldiers whether that be from the
Wagner group or trawling prisons in
Russia so of course we do want to see
peace talks but they need to be
meaningful and ultimately the contents
of those uh peace talks the the
threshold uh that uh that might be met
in terms of bringing peace has got to be
decided by the Ukrainian people the
Ukrainian president because of course
they're the ones whose sons and
daughters are being killed in this world
do you sense there's any changes on that
front do you sense that it could be the
possibility that there are talks well at
the moment I'm not really seeing
anything coming from the Russian side
that gives me confidence that uh
Vladimir Putin is entering these talks
in good faith the The Wider rhetoric is
still very uh confrontational But
ultimately as I say we want to see this
resolved we would prefer to see it
resolved sooner rather than later but
that resolution has got to be meaningful
um what if Russia pulled back to just
occupying Crimea would that in your mind
be a a fair basis to have peace talks so
I I don't want to I don't want to start
setting the conditions for what Ukraine
and the Ukrainian people should accept
ultimately it's their country that
they're defending it's their sons and
daughters that have been lost it's their
homes their infrastructure that has been
damaged by
um Vladimir Putin's Invasion and it's up
for them to decide the circumstances
under which they'll be willing to
negotiate for peace okay
um lots of other stories in the news
this week including a documentary that's
come out of America Harry and Megan I
don't know if you've had a chance to see
it with your busy schedule
um given that the row over that and also
comments made by a member of the the
public at a reception at the palace a
couple of weeks ago do you think the
royal family has a problem with racism
well I'm not gonna I'm not going to
discuss the documentary not least
because
um when I get a spare moment I I'm
trying to catch up with stranger things
when I when I watch television rather
than rather than that particular some of
your colleagues think they should lose
their titles so
um
my view in all the interactions that I
have had with the royal family and I do
have the opportunity to do so more than
most because of my role as foreign
secretary
um I've I've seen a a group of people
who are passionate about supporting the
Britain as it is
um the uh the the King has spoken in the
past when he was uh Prince of Wales
about uh about the wonder that is the
Multicultural nature of this uh country
I get to travel the world and when you
do you get to look back at the UK as
others see us and I'm very proud of what
I see I see a a very well integrated
multi-ethnic
um a country that I think can be very
proud of its diverse Heritage and I
think the Royal Family's attitude to
this country reflects the modern country
that we that we see that's my personal
experience but I also think that that is
something that the whole world sees when
they look at us
they also look at us in terms of
football did you get a chance to watch
it last night oh I did I did and I know
exactly what's going to happen next my
my my my good friend the French prime
minister was sending me a little little
messages uh just before she boarded a
flight so I know that she didn't watch
the game because she was in the air I'm
dreading to think when she wakes up uh
this morning what what uh what messages
await me
um look it was it was a good match I
think uh I think France had the first
half
England had the second half
um I I mean I I think I think our boys
did incredibly incredibly well we should
be really proud of them tough result but
we should be proud of them and the Anton
cordial remains in place
uh you know wishing France well for the
next round I mean some people would say
should he be doing that but look
um sport brings people together I mean
that's that's the point sport brings
people together
um it was a it was a good match I
um I've got my I got my eye on Morocco I
just I there's something there and it's
incredibly exciting African African team
uh going that far
um
this is yeah the round of eight is um is
is I think always the most exciting bit
of the tournament typically as you get
close to the final it gets everyone gets
a little bit more cautious
um but but yeah look there's some really
good things there is some really
interesting results could be interesting
final
James Bradley thank you very much thank
you